on ne peut pas vivre avec le lait c'est
pourquoi si le lait on arrive toujours
pas envie plus de 50 ans séparent ces
deux témoignages de productrice laitière
pourtant le même constat le malaise dans
la profession est profond une profession
qui a dû évoluer à marche forcée dans
les années 70 la communauté économique
européenne encourage et alors les
exploitations à produire plus il fallait
donc investir pour de nouveaux
équipements importants les agriculteurs
s'endettent pour investir dans des
nouvelles fermes modernes des nouvelles
races de vaches une nouvelle forme
d'alimentation une frénésie critiqué par
certains agriculteurs
on le regarde plus ce qu'est ce qu'on
veut quand même si c'est de l'eau
blanchi du moment que la vache donne une
grande quantité puisque ces pays au
litre
mais dans les années 80 cette
surproduction entraîne des excédents de
lait alors en 1984 le couperet tombe
avec l'instauration des quotas
alors concrètement quels producteurs
français de lait vous allez demander de
diminuer la production mais tous de
manière à ce que chacun est une
diminution la plus petite possible alors
que les agriculteurs comptait sur
l'augmentation de la production pour
rembourser leurs prêts ils doivent à
présent produire moins il y avait que le
collet pour nous pour nous sortir pour
pouvoir vivre
mais si c'est impossible d'augmenter
notre production nous reste plus qu'une
chose à mettre la clé sous la porte je
pense
les années passent et les grèves se
répète
les producteurs sont dépendants de
toutes parts alors ils demandent la fin
des quotas afin de pouvoir produire plus
1er avril 2015
leur souhait est exaucé mais il ya un
revers à la médaille
pour lui cette libéralisation va
favoriser les producteurs de l'europe du
nord et livrer les plus petits surtout
dans le sud à la guerre des prix et cela
a déjà commencé
le marché autrefois gérée par l'europe
est complètement libéralisé en 2015 et
sans quotas
le marché est inondé de l'est et les
prix s'effondrent le lait on arrive
toujours pas envie parce qu'il nous faut
34 centimes est là pour ce mois ci on
est à 29 centimes du litre de lait pour
s'en sortir les agriculteurs sont forcés
aujourd'hui d'investir pour produire
plus et produire plus pour rembourser
ses investissements la profession a muté
en quelques années il y avait 150 mille
exploitations laitières en 1995 il n'en
reste plus que cinquante six mille
aujourd'hui pour la même production de
lait les petites exploitations sont
forcés de s'agrandir pour ne pas mourir
[Musique]